is teaching us what's right what's wrong
especially in the last 50 years when
women didn't have as much power so
nowadays we're all being careful i just
told you an example where i asked the
lady i was talking to can you not wear
that and i'm telling you it was so
difficult because if i go above and
beyond i'm in trouble or i could be
offending her it's so marginal now so
again
how much power do we have telling our
daughter who and who not to date
do you get what i mean so it's not like
it's that easy what you presented
because we have to look at it as a whole
our wife may intervene and be like don't
tell a talker what to do because now
you're embracing sexism so that's where
our society is at it's so it's not that
easy for us to answer these things okay
so may or may not be dating and you take
wait if i mean i would um as a man i'll
still be like god damn why him of all
people okay if billy down the road is
good andrew
but not andrew can i just check
something you said you fell into a
relationship or into a situation with
with someone younger
how do you
was that just a like a miscommunication
of words how do you fall into a
situation with someone younger i'm
talking well a bit of both so yes and no
the lord me um sometimes you find
yourself in a situation where you start
to connect with someone and despite your
better intentions
you have fallen for someone so but if
you've connected with them and you fall
in with someone and if they're not under
the legal age
then there's no problem what do you mean
like so if if you've fallen into some
sort of relationship or you've fallen
for somebody and you've realized that
they're younger so
you personally
do have an issue with the age gap thing
so regardless of the fact you've fallen
for that person no i think for me it's
like and we're talking legal agents
first and foremost before yeah yeah
that's
misconstrued um but i think for me it's
like the elements of the things that i'm
attracted to come with a certain element
of age i'm not talking i'm not trying to
date like someone five years ten years
older than me but
a 19 year old 18 year old's like it's
kind of like does that joe rogan uh joke
where he says it just sounds like
they're just learning how to talk
there's that element of like we don't
connect in certain ways but if you run
into someone who
that isn't an issue like if that's not
the feeling you get when you're
interacting with them then you can still
you know that can be pushed to the side
and you can still hang out and if you
develop something and they're genuinely
you know someone you want to be around
all the time then
you know at some point you have to look
at yourself like am i really gonna throw
this person i really like away just
because they're 20. well yeah exactly
and i think the the comment about like
18 19 year olds um like just learning to
talk whatever i think you can have some
18 19 year olds that have been through a
hell of a lot in their life and you know
could be much more mature than somebody
who's 29 30. i don't think that age
necessarily
dictates how mature you are as a person
but they'll always be they'll always be
elements like you can't pretend to be 50
years old when you're not like no
so your experience is limited but your
your maturity and your intelligence
isn't necessarily because some of the
most intelligent people in the world or
some of the most talented musicians
might be children of course
but yeah i mean i've met some 50 year
olds that act like they're 15. yeah yeah
sure
i'm like some old yeah
true but then you could even argue he's
35 but he is that he sometimes goes
around acting like he is like 18 19.
it's true but every so often he'll like
have a sober moment and you can see the
maturity cut through and i think there's
there's a limit it's like there's a
ceiling that you have
in general i would say experience
maturity well
you know what they say about women as
like they stop maturing as soon as they
get pretty oh
and then they start again once it goes
away oh
that's that's savage
fenty um let's do the next clip blessing
um
actually do do the third clip
can i throw in can we i don't know i've
been seeing the um dicaprio um
oh yeah can we connect that because
everyone's like i look through the
comment section in him
you hear he's got another 22 year old
yeah but everyone's giving him a lot of
you know and i'm like
i is that in 1822 yeah
but the thing i had a problem with is
that it's like there seems to be this
element of like oh you someone women
only develop their cerebral cortex
whatever 25 and i'm like you say that
but then when you're 18 of the club you
want x y like it just it seems like a
double standard or like i want to have
your cake needed two situations like
i've been knew what i was doing since i
was 16.
i feel like anything that they're like
oh i didn't know when i was 60 i'm like
um i wouldn't agree with that fully i
just feel like when i was like i just
feel like it's an excuse like you make
decisions they're definitely things i
would definitely not do again if i could
go back ten years to seven years
i think everyone could say that right
regardless of how mature or experienced
they are everyone regrets certain
decisions that they've made yeah so i
wouldn't say i wouldn't say i know my
like even the whole like
you've said on other podcasts you've
always known yourself i think you can
feel that way but if you had a chance
like put yourself in a situation six
years ago i think there are ways you
would look at it and be like
so i mean i think experience like breeds
maturity but i don't i don't think like
i would never take accountability off of
myself and say like blame it on my age
and like i didn't know what i was doing
like i made the decision with the
information i had at the time now i have
more information i'd make a different
decision but it's still my own fault of
course yeah yeah i agree um why don't
you make it full screen blessing
if you don't
um
oh this was
that is so funny for me to clean sorry
go ahead
oh yeah you gotta turn that one off
you can just exit that we're done with
it
okay you can do that too
yeah if if if i were you i'm making that
argument i could i could rationalize the
argument you just did if most of the
girls that i dated or that i was with
had the iq of somebody who cannot move
think or do anything and it just stuck
on the side of the [ __ ] curb so yeah
i guess maybe you would have this
experience if moses did were zero iq
brain frozen yeah but it doesn't make
sense in the real world because you
don't park your [ __ ] girl on the curb
at the club they move they talk they do
[ __ ] so it's not [ __ ] it's not it's
not the danger of other guys doing doing
[ __ ] right because they can still think
and the the the
the loss of potent the potential that
that one get of a million will do some
crazy [ __ ] and and is going to
forcefully bring your home right is for
that smallest is far outweighed by the
fun enjoyment and fulfillment that they
get by going the club in the first place
that's interesting but you also have to
understand because we are different
individuals living very different lives
and i'm not going to sit here and
comment on your relationships because i
don't understand them because i don't
know them okay you have to
i am in i am at a status of life or any
woman who gets with me understands that
to be with a man of my caliber there are
certain sacrifices which must be made
you do not get to be
with a kickboxing world champion
multi-millionaire whose entire life is
completely on track and live a life of
spoiled princess and then also say to
that man i go to the club whenever the
[ __ ] i want you might be able to say
that to some other men but you can't say
it to me so a woman which may say to you
i'm a unique special snowflake i do
whatever the [ __ ] i want if she was in
my presence she wouldn't say that now
because women are a reflection of their
man it's not hard to get a woman who
sits there and says you know what i
don't go to the club without my man
because i adore my man if the man
is worthy of such adoration if the
woman's sitting there going well i'm
with him but no he doesn't tell me what
to do that's the man's problem it's
nothing to do with the woman females are
all the same it's all about the man
they're with i have no trouble and no
arguments in my life telling women they
don't go to the club by themselves zero